derniers ajustements pour la fête des
grands vins de beaune habituellement
4000 visiteurs s'y pressent mais cette
année les organisateurs craignent que
certains ne soient découragés par les
manifestations à venir
c'est le grand public qui nous fait
vivre la manifestation c'est vivre
l'opération la manifestation puisque
c'est les personnes qui achètent les
rentiers qui paye sont venus déguster
des vins depuis vogel est juste achats
d'huile dans sa grande boum mois le
monde - à moins de rentrées donc on veut
déficits et les liquidités déficit qui
paiera le déficit et gilet jaune ne
devrait laisser passer les
automobilistes qu'au compte gouttes
ils seront filtrés à deux entrées de la
ville de beaune cette commerçante qui
mise énormément sur ces trois jours de
festivités se résout à faire avec
c'est le plus grand week-end de l'année
on va dire l'un des plus gros avant
avant le grand froid d'hiver
alors on croiser les doigts pour que ça
tombe pas ce week end là bas ça tombe ce
week end là bas on compose avec cet
hôtel réalise un meilleur chiffre
d'affaires en 4 jours que pendant tout
le mois de janvier ou février
alors le gérant ne veut pas non plus
s'inquiéter l'hôtel est complet depuis
ce soir et nous on a des prix fixes pour
quatre shows dont qui sont obligés d
état d'un changement de date pour
l'instant on n'a eu aucune menace aucun
problème et comme cela ne suffisait pas
ce week-end il ya aussi l'interruption
de la ligne lyon mâcon pour une
importante opération de signalisation
mais la sncf rassure ses voyageurs au
départ de la gare du creusot
des bus de substitution partiront
direction bonnes pour que l'édition 2018
reste sur de bons rails